if apologies are due tonight they are
due from Christopher Hitchens
who has just run through one of the
longest series of misrepresentations of
the Catholic church that I have heard in
a long time
it really is I think quite telling
that in coping with emotion which says
the Catholic church is a Force for good
in the world he has to go back to the
Crusades
in order to try and disprove it or if
that's slightly too far back the sack of
Constantinople
he
can't actually look at the force that
the Catholic churches in the world today
but I do nevertheless
want to join him on his ground though
not sharing any of his conclusions and
just look at some of the things which he
has stated
he has said
and actually you know no Pope
pronouncing ex-cathedral could ever
sound more convinced of Truth than when
Christopher Hitchens utters something
incredibly questionable but he has said
with that certainty which characterizes
his utterances
that the Catholic church has had a
history of anti-semitism
let us just look
at the record of the Catholic Church
when the Jewish community
was under the most serious threat
that it has faced in recent centuries
and just look at the role that the
Catholic Church played
in the last World War
Mr Hitchens ignores
the thousands of Jews
who were secreted
and rescued in churches and monasteries
throughout Europe
uh tremendous risk
to the priests and the monks and the
nuns who were hiding them
he ignores the three thousand Jews who
in the course of that conflict
took refuge in the Pope's own
Summer Palace
he contradicts flatly
the statement of so many prominent Jews
after 1945
who expressed gratitude to Pius XII
even to the extent
of sending the Israeli Philharmonic
Orchestra to Stage a concert in the
Pope's honor not I think something that
they would have done if they had thought
he had been anti-Semitic
but rather they recognize that the
Catholic Church throughout that period
acted
within the limitations of the time
as a Force for good
Martin Gilbert and Michael Burley
historians have very considerable repute
point to the large number of Catholics
who found themselves in Dhaka
and of course we should remember
that any Christian not just Catholic but
any Christian
joining the SS
had first to renounce
his faith
so I do not think that a charge of
anti-Semitism can stand up yes it is
quite true
that the New Testament says
that the first century Sanhedrin
made a very major contribution
to the death of Christ
so also did the Romans
and indeed its Pontius Pilate that we
remember in the Creed every Sunday not
the Sanhedrin
yet I do not recall Mr Hitchens
suggesting that because of that the
modern Catholic Church is anti-italian
I'd rather thought it was quite Pro
Italian
he also suggests
that the pope welcomed back a holocaust
denying Bishop
let us first remember that the bishop in
question was originally expelled for
disobedience
upon being reinstated and upon
reiterating his views
the pope a fact conveniently ignored by
Mr Hitchens
commanded him to repent
commanded him to deny what he had said
you would think from listening to Mr
Hitchens that the Catholic Church alone
has been responsible for atrocities
throughout history
if you are going to judge the Catholic
church at any given stage in history
then you have to judge it against
the standards that were prevailing at
the time
and condemning the Inquisition which was
a horrible thing
condemning the Inquisition
in isolation
from condemning just about the whole in
fact the whole of European society which
at that time
rejoiced in punishment and torture as a
means of dealing with criminality and
with treason and with wrongdoing
to try and divorce the Catholic Church
from that and say that it was uniquely
guilty
under the Inquisition
is simply trying to look back at
centuries gone past and apply a standard
that nobody applied at the time
and coming nearer to our day of course
Christopher Hitchens is right and who
could possibly dispute with him that the
abuse of children
of innocent children
is one in fact it is the worst offense
that anybody can commit of that no doubt
but again he seems to think
that the Catholic church should have had
some unique insight
which demonstrably
with lacking in society as a whole and
I'll give examples at the time
let's remember that in the 1970s not the
Crusades not the sack of Constantinople
but in the 1970s the National Council
for civil liberties in this country
allowed the pedophile information
Exchange
to affiliate to it
and the National Council for civil
liberties had extremely respectable
people at its head including Harriet
Harman and Patricia Hewitt
would anybody seriously say that they
condone child abuse
they were acting in the ignorance of the
time
magistrates at that time magistrates
some to even get before judges sometimes
magistrates were awarding a few months
in prison for that heinous crime
I myself in the 1980s trained as a
Samaritan one of the things we were
taught was how to handle it when we got
callers about child abuse
we were not taught then
because they didn't know
that actually there was no way
that somebody who abused would simply
stop
and it was only in the mid-1990s and
don't I know it because I was in the
home office at the time that we actually
introduced in this country a register of
sex offenders do not expect the Catholic
Church somehow when that was the state
of knowledge at the time
to have acted in a unique and completely
different way in retrospect yes of
course
in retrospect yup in retrospect it
should have done so should the
magistrates so should the Samaritans so
should the National Council of civil
liberties
but when we ask who whether the Catholic
church is a Force for good
let's just try to imagine a world today
without for example
the billions of pounds that are poured
into overseas aid by the Catholic Church
contributing year on year more than any
single nation
imagine the developing world
had been left without the input of the
medicine and the education that was
brought to it by the missions
imagine the absence of those collections
Sunday upon Sunday for famine relief
imagine the absence of the church in the
local community
I know well that when I was in the
Department of Employment and in the home
office and we were setting up
initiatives single regeneration budget
whatever it might be we relied on the
church
our churches every bit as much as we
relied on local councils and on other
organizations
we play a vital role
and you don't need to be a Catholic to
acknowledge that we play that role what
is the church
it is its members
it is the nuns and the monks and the
priests and the lay workers and the
congregations
it is not just the hierarchy of the
church
and I believe that the church to which I
belong
is a massive massive Force for good but
let us not just keep the debate at that
level
I knew somehow that when we were here
tonight we would be discussing child
abuse and condoms they came in the end I
was almost thought we were going to get
through an entire speech without condoms
from Christopher Hitchens but we got
them at the end
if he has a Creed it would be I believe
in condoms
so
but that that is not what the Catholic
church is about it isn't only
about the physical relief of the poor it
isn't only about the work it does on
Earth but it is the message that it
preaches and that message is one of Hope
that message is one of salvation
and it is all very well for some people
in an intellectual arrogance to say we
can do without that
but actually billions of people across
the world live by that message of Hope
and of Salvation they try to live
by The Commandments and also by the
interpretation of those Commandments by
Christ
yeah sometimes they fail
sometimes their leaders fail human
beings do fail
but overwhelmingly I say to you tonight
with no apology or whatever
that a world without the Catholic Church
would be poor off would be more hopeless
and would be a worse place in which to
live